ouch good morning everyone welcome back
to gamespot live i'm richie and today
is caldera day caldera warzone new
pacific map
and i'm so excited to get started let me
just show you
what we got going on here
i'm richie by the way i think i don't
know if i said that i don't even have my
lower third
going crazy let's see
here oh here we go okay
let's just have a look here we go
that is paulina
from vanguard
with the with the scar from the future
uh fighting off
the world war ii resistance oh my god
let's just go let's just jump this is
this is a lot to take in so why don't i
say less and just jump into the game
okay i got into one match um
and it was really cool what i like so
far is they give you a lot of those um
those planes the planes are now in war
zone like confirmed for sure
and there's an airstrip with a bunch of
them i got in but i couldn't drive it so
i crashed it but i lived it was cool and
now i just hope that this doesn't take
that long servers are probably slammed
but there we go yeah we got a good shot
there it is okay let me just mute
everybody here
i think i did
no no they just don't have mics okay
great let's do it
yes hey chat yeah they do have planes
confirmed
aaron in the chat what's up man aaron
30 minutes until halo infinite campaign
oh yeah dude can't wait for that what a
what a big day
okay i'm gonna get this mic a little bit
more out of my way
and wish me luck
this is for uh if you've if you
own vanguard you should be able to play
this today 24 hours early
check this out i can't use the new guns
a modern gun so i got to use default
classes
the bar i like the bar it's just a
little
chugs a little i need i need faster fire
rate wow here we are
probably gonna get killed right away
uh but i just want to look around while
i can wow look at this
it's crazy we're never we're never going
back to verdansk unless they do like a
you know
apex legend style
you know
throwback playlist which they probably
will for dance
may not be gone forever but
caldera is here to stay at least for at
least for a while wow okay
nice
trainings
wish me luck everyone oh i'm playing on
playstation 5.
david says i'm going to get it for
christmas nice
excuse me that's great
prepare for vanguard guns meta yeah you
know what's cool though like this game
mode that i'm playing you can only use
vanguard guns
which
is already proving to be kind of goofy
like if you're playing vanguard you can
you already know the guns are like all
over the place
but at least it's not like a hundred
guns like regular war zone i'm the squad
leader i don't know where to go
let's uh let's let's let's keep it
low-key oh someone already picked i like
that
yeah i'll confirm
let's go there
i'll pass the leadership to you
wish me luck guys
hey richie how do you like the new maps
mark so far brandon hernandez back in
the chat good to see you man this is my
first real match so
stay tuned uh because i haven't made a
full-blown like you know
opinion i played one match and you know
died pretty quick anyway
let's get into it that's the buy station
it's a little wooden box now
friendly
we need guns let's go let's go
i hear one ah
someone can add that little handgun if
they want yeah
share with my friends here
okay we need more buildings i'm gonna go
this way and look for look for guns
oh wait what am i doing you guys
i have armor let's load up right now
armor guys armor armor up
oh shoot bad guys already
before this uh
what am i doing give me that
there was a little cut scene before
caldera like officially started and it
was just the uh the trailer from
yesterday
um just basically showing captain
butcher showing up to the island and
then um
you know preparing for uh
for battle royale
okay someone was up there
yeah they're still fighting
this is a really short-range gun so i'm
gonna oh you guys hear that
whoa
we should get to the airstrip
someone's here
this hand guard on this gun is crazy is
this the new gun i didn't even realize
someone's in there watch out
no
i should have gone earlier
that's not the guy was shooting earlier
ah crap
okay they got him they got hurt
ah they took our friend ooh an stg [ __ ]
oh my god
[Laughter]
we're surrounded
nope i'm gonna lose that gunfight
oh look at my gun glitching out oh no
this guy my man is hiding
me too though i'm scared we're
surrounded
[Laughter]
damn it
excellent move from bikes
well at least we get to see the gulag
and i can catch up with you guys how's
chat doing why is this game still gray
yeah the color palette it's kind of a
little more muted than i realized
yeah the gun is bugged that's for sure
i like me the stg44 but i mainly use the
m1 garand i mainly like the m1 garand
yeah
this is not
uh this is live for people who played
vanguard or who own vanguard
oh man mp44 all right wish me luck guys
should have gone right i'm ready
regretting no i did it wow that took no
time at all
time to kill was really fast
hey my friends here and there
what are you doing
all right
well where should we go let's find the
airstrip
maybe there are still planes yeah look
at that
why don't we try it out friend
everyone's landed you know maybe we have
a shot here
my right eyes itchy i didn't wake up
that long ago
just reading the chat yeah if you do own
it you should be able to play oh no
that was a plane trying to shoot me out
of the sky
he's gonna go again i'm out of here
that would be cool oh i would be so
proud if i just picked a guy off from
like out of the sky like that
incredible he knows what i'm doing too
he's probably gonna circle back and like
try to kill me
sorry there we go
hey have my gun from the gulag
come on friendly let's go
okay
push to accelerate push to take off
wow look at us i'm not even gonna shoot
that guy i'm gonna fly around
whoa
can i do like a oh there's a bad guy no
i'm not even gonna bother i'm gonna try
to do a barrel roll
you want you want to keep actually
playing the game team me i'm having fun
here just flying
there's a bad guy over there
you can jump out if you want teammate
not me oh
how do you like there's no other place
to safely land this i assume than the
airstrip so i probably just gotta jump
out that's probably why they give you so
many planes oh these aren't enemies
these are like
sorry i'm probably talking way too much
but everything is so
everything is so new
and my teammates gone he definitely
confirmed
he landed
no
[Laughter]
ah
yeah let's just accept it report it and
move on guys damn let me switch over to
this
uh intro that's this one
okay stupid
damn
all right actually no i didn't need to
do that let's go back to uh
this
i just hope i can get into another lobby
i can't believe it crashed
i can't believe it crashed uh i'm just
sad it did
rats
yep
servers are hot baby
it's okay and first impressions though
let me know in the let me know in the
chat you guys i mean we only saw like
that had to be like five minutes
but you know i got in the plane i got to
look around what do you guys think so
far
oh the new gulag was also there yeah
that's cool
hello hello
all right let's try this again
i have a good feeling um a lot of people
actually i don't know i don't know um i
was just about to say a lot of people
probably don't have vanguard
uh which is the only way you can play
this new warzone map early
so i was hopeful the servers wouldn't be
too
[Music]
too uh too crazy but they might be it
sounds like they're crashing that's for
sure
vanguard royale
that's what i'm playing now i believe
really nice map
you were just laughing though i don't
know
if you're
if you're just joking
oh yeah it did crash for sure
yes let's uh let's try to get another
oops
come on pings stay low
i can't even make a class um but i'll
show you guys the battle pass that also
launches today
if you buy the battle pass you get all
this stuff right away
a few skins
and then here's
tier one
two and so on
that's funny
nothing out of the ordinary the store is
also back and it's full of vanguard
exclusive stuff like this dude
there was another cool one that i liked
this one's cool hey i got into a game
okay we'll talk more about that later
really nice map at least enemies can see
clearly in this map
i don't know did you did you guys have
visibility problems in verdansk it was
it was kind of the colors were kind of
like
green and brown but i don't think i had
visibility oh well
it was such a big map you're bound to
have visibility issues no matter what
all right let's try again
nope can't pick any of these
maybe i will try the bar this time
whoa
wow beautiful
oh [ __ ] go go go go
that guy's just getting slaughtered
i'm next uh
oh no
no leave me alone
nearby that's that's unsettling get away
from me
there's a bad guy up there
he's out for blood
i wonder if i can sneak up on him
i'm just gonna shoot him one time
hey man
nope didn't work i forgot i gotta do the
the crouch thing that's that's how you
say friendly
alright let's do it
wow
get used to this guys this is how war
zone looks now
there i am on the back left with my gas
mask
grim reaper 365 damn killing them all
day every day 365.
cash drop
wow hey there's the volcano
peak
oh i thought it was an active volcano is
there one i thought there
was looking around
oh well our our leader isn't picking a
spot and i think he just jumped
well here we go
i'll just follow orange here
wait where are you going
yeah that's a good spot let's go
copy that
somewhere i probably just walked past it
here we go
my character's already wearing a gas
mask that's funny
[Laughter]
you guys uh do you see the new scg
upgrade here
it's looking great
yeah this is awesome
oh
my god
oh man i thought it would like clear out
if i switched weapons
this is
this is me aiming down sights right now
uh
i'm a little sad because i want the stg
but i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
drop it off
thank goodness
let's see if i can try again
no
man
oh well
good old thompson it is
oh they killed my teammate during all
this foolery all this tomfoolery
crap
surviving
here another box i'm gonna be quiet
oh
this is where i started from why didn't
i see that box
oh shoot
okay he jumped down
no please
come on
i had shots on him but then
i went out of control thompson is nuts
excuses excuses i'm in the guru log
let's go
wow
actually oh my god terrifying what is
that vacuum car
this looks different but then down here
it kind of just looks like
the the most current gulags
man there was some blocky
visual problems here texture gun
how do you think these bugs are funny
though just lazy
lazy of the devs
it ain't easy making the game man i'm
not here to uh
i mean i'm just glad that thompson
worked because yeah that was uh it was
not a functional weapon but i mean it
was funny
wish me luck but if you lose
going all the way
around how did i
wow you know i didn't deserve to make it
what did what did butcher say i play
like [ __ ] because that's true
yeah okay i have two teammates alive
let's let's let's watch someone at a
higher skill level play
what's that
a little propane there
something
hmm
i don't think let's see he has enough to
buy me back let me do the old whoopsie
daisy
it's like please
what do you say would you consider it
that water isn't like loaded in all the
way
hmm
this is also new everything i can't like
uh
i only played two matches so far
everything will be new for like a week
man
they fired their q a staff and look what
happened is that true hey look octopus
this dude is dying forget the octopus
man run for your life
what are you doing
maybe i can switch to the next player i
don't want to watch this guy get gassed
out
he's down
bro
i won't let you can't believe it i don't
want to believe it
yo where are we going
i guess it doesn't matter everything is
new let's have a tour
what is this
well that was weird
i don't know if you can hear me now but
um
obs crashed i've never seen that before
i'm seeing everything back in the green
so i hope i'm okay but
i can only
uh
can only do so much about that i hope i
hope you guys are seeing the feed
everything is looking fine on my end now
but i got a pop-up that was like
obs failed or quit or something like
that
weird
all right this guy means business he's
pinging everything
let's go
what's my backup gun
okay
okay
everyone uh helping me out
at gamespot uh in the
in the chat just trying to make sure
we're back online um great okay aaron
says good to go
appreciate your patience guys that was
weird uh it crashed and i just thought i
didn't think it'd come back but it did
it obs just took a dump on me
okay i gotta get out of here
i didn't
i lost my teammates they're up ahead
[Music]
good lord
whoa
oh no
i got my teammate in via
airplane
oh no it's this guy
let me flank around flank around
oh god that took forever
this gun is
never mind i'm gonna stop blaming
everything on everyone
take it
surrounded
man my teammates were so good too i blew
it well i got one guy but it took
forever
that was a cool blueprint for the sdg
had like a shark on it i think i have
that what am i saying
loading next player all right oh yeah
one of one of them gets to go to the
gulag
no watch out
f in the chat
back out and try again
wow
what a morning
why can't console get feel the vision
i don't know man uh it did for cold war
and it worked out fine in my
opinion i don't know i don't know i was
really sad to hear that this morning
it makes such a difference i don't even
go all the way
i forget like i i it's normally set to
80 to feel the vision
and i put it to like 100 out of like 100
and whatever 20 150
um
and it makes such a difference it really
feels unfair that um
pc gets it but we don't i don't know why
i don't know why that's the case
we know it's possible
but if you guys have a theory let me
know down in the chat um
because i have no idea why
man i cannot believe obs crashed on me
like that
okay here we go
9yk3 no in the chat he asks is this the
playstation 4 version no this is ps5
i can't get the update i'm on xbox in
the uk do i need early access oh yeah um
rocky road if you
if you own vanguard and you played
within the last like few days
you should have early access to this new
map but if you don't own vanguard
or you have it but you haven't you know
played in like a week i don't think
you'll get access it was kind of a weird
rule but
um i also don't know
how the time variations differ from the
uk you said you're in the uk
so i hope i hope that helps
oh man we're seeing a lot of uh
i'm not the only one with technical
issues today
i hope you guys all get in just remember
you gotta have
you gotta have vanguard and you you have
to
you have to have played vanguard
uh some at some point yesterday to like
claim your spot to get in today it's a
weird rule it's like a club or something
anyway
this map will be available for everyone
tomorrow whether or not you even have
vanguard
nice you got a free operator good stuff
good stuff
hey i'm the leader oh no
i'm just gonna switch that out there we
go
here's the map friends
this person wants to drop right away
let's go
i like it
there's a lot of people here i hear a
lot of parachutes deploying
uh i'm gonna maybe go to this little
house instead
come on there we go
okay
someone could use that
what
belly pinging
well at least this was a safe landing
there's not a lot of stuff around here
where are you guys going you want to go
further that way
what is this like a gun i gotta check
this out
or at least i'm gonna take a look um
this is how you shoot down planes i
guess or one of the ways
whoa
that's fine
that'd be cool i can probably
uh hurt people with this thing but it
doesn't go that low this is the lowest
it goes
dang that was cool
i didn't even fire one bullet though
what am i doing what's wrong with this
game
oh my god okay it's not doesn't appear
to be obs cutting out it's the game
inactivity what the
what
what is wrong with this game
uh i was moving i was moving the
joysticks and stuff
could i take a seat on the aaa gun i
guess not
goodness
no mercy this game's like hey you're not
gonna move we gotta we gotta get more
people in here uh you've been kicked for
inactivity
what the hell
use a vehicle okay oh we did last game i
was passenger
but uh maybe i can try to use a plane
the first match we joined i got into a
plane with a teammate
and we flew around and then it crashed
it crashed again
well that wasn't really a cr
i would say it was a crash because it
was an inaccurate
reason for getting kicked
so whack
use the helicopter or hell five am i
sure what you mean alive
oh wish me luck i'll try again
um
three-line rifle i'll use this again
whoa crap
hey this reminds me of uh
making from uh world at war remember
that map they even no not me yeah i
think it was making
this this same style hut looks like um
one of the maps from world at war
i'd be thrilled if it really were it
looks a lot like this
this might be a general style for these
huts but this really looks like
what
oh no look my clock is crashing
everything's crashing
oh
oh no it's all buggy oh no
you know what this might just be fun to
see how many uh glitches we can find
look there's a rope
i'm on the top of my plane
we all have gas masks gas masks
oh hey alive oh yeah no problem i i just
wanted to be sure i knew what you were
saying there in chat welcome i'm glad
you're here
oh man wish me luck
it was it was a really buggy start
crap it almost feels like um
you know when your internet's uh uh
lagging your game
it kind of feels like that but i'm
hardwired into the wall right now like
no way is that happening
all right orange changed his mind he
wants to go here
fine
we're not alone dude
crap we're definitely not alone well
there's only one guy okay
[Music]
i'll take this if you don't want it then
okay obs is in the green now
hopefully we're just seeing
oh my god
that's so loud
oh it's cool though
uh yeah obs is now in the green so i'm
just wanting to
i wasn't talking for a bit because it
was all red and i just assumed i wasn't
even getting through to you guys
got one
ah there's no door here damn it
no
oh my god this gun i cannot oh my god
more people i gotta reload this thing
and
mentally
regroup here
someone's still over there i saw him
man
okay okay
get that armor
where'd that last person go my goodness
thanks for hanging in there chat it got
really intense for a sec there i only
got one kill it's
oh well
where's my gun oh my goodness
oh my god
oh my god i almost died inside
uh yeah i'll take that over this
thompson definitely
i'm no good with the thompson folks
this one's better this one's got more
attachments
what i don't want this thing
okay
okay
okay let's let's regroup here
where should we even go this whole map
is just oh this whole map is just brand
new
someone's around here
oh that's my that's my teammate okay
uh
oh yeah
okay we can see this guy frozen no it's
me
what is going on guys
oh no oh no oh
dear
alive i see you in the chat
cool little emoji there
yeah let's get the load out okay
look everything's goofing up on me guys
this stinks
uh
i'll stick with this yeah
maybe swap this one out
there we go
all right let's get that heck out of
here
whoa
i haven't been in those planes nearly
enough i should be i should be landing
on those planes every time i start a new
match they're pretty cool
what where do you want to go
oh okay store oh yeah our teammate's
still here let's go our teammate is dead
but we can buy him back that's what i
meant to say
wait there's a shop right here let's go
to this one instead
why is it doing this to me
bounty inverted okay good that's good
news i feel like
this match is like glitching out a
little but at least i'm
why did i close that door um at least
i'm still in it it's not um crashing as
i knock on wood
what i didn't do anything
oh no
i bought our teammate back he went for
the loadout and then he got hit dang it
they're gonna have to come around here
no come back uh did he get sniped i
can't risk going out there can i
who shot him i need to know
so i don't get hit too
[ __ ] no time to think no time to think
come on
we can do it
all right
we did it
wow for once that little
uh i don't even remember what they're
called they came in handy that little
guard wall
let's get the hell out of here
imagine looking forward to the one map
getting replaced hmm
you can't even play the story mode in
modern warfare after the update man
maybe okay it's good to know that i mean
it's bad to know that a lot of people
are having issues but um
at least at least it puts me at ease
because a lot of issues that have
happened on the stream this morning oh
can i give him money
here wait do you want
we already have a loadout do you want
actually let me give you everything how
about that just take all do it do what
you want with it
get a selfie it's on me
i'll cover you we gotta get out of here
cool beans okay let's roll
one stream i swear i'll i'll play with
my actual
friends
uh so we can have comms i'm playing i
always play with randoms and i like it
it's
playing with randoms is always a unique
experience i get more dubs that way
actually
sometimes it's weird like less
communication is more just you know
pings and stuff like that
i'll take that one
okay well this map
so far is looking really nice not a lot
of action in this match which is good
because we can we can sort of look
around i don't want to hide out too much
i want you guys to see the map
but
um i also just don't you know i don't
want to die immediately
what's that i heard money my money money
money
all right i'll go up with blue up here
we should we should move up
oh look at this look at this beautiful
guys
never mind there we go you can climb
rocks so much easier now look at that
before it was just impossible there were
just hills you couldn't climb
this all looks climable that's great
news let me see it can i can i cheese it
it's not even cheese in it dude i'm just
climbing
wait
nope nope
there we go yeah cool oh they made it so
much easier to climb they made it
possible to climb is what i like
i'll take that ar over this
um i like this gun but i don't love it
the the fire rate
is really fast and i need something a
little a little more chill
okay we're all alive though this is this
is this is great hey
lunar wolf needs a plate of armor armor
up where is he
he's way the f over there
he's fighting somebody
oh goodness
there he is getting into fights and
dying
i'll watch our backs papa smurf is
watching our backs never mind
papa smurf
there he is
oh i don't know if i should have done
that
did i blow our cover
remove this before we get into battle
oh
[Music]
oh no the smoke
or the the gas excuse me
run run run run i need a faster gun
let's go run run run
my gun is so
buggy dude oh crap
crap
is my teammate oh god he got crushed
right behind me i'm toast
there he is
got one
i think there's one more besides that
car
[ __ ]
all right
they're gonna flank me from the side i
think
wrong
equipment oh well
that worked out woohoo
i want to buy my friends back is there a
shop nearby the
ice station
someone's still over there okay at least
this guy is here with me uh i forget his
name in the orange but
he's good
i'm not i'm lucky
okay okay let's roll
area clear my goodness
yup erin it ain't over till it's over i
thought i lost that one
let's get to that buy station homie
all right i'm in
dude crashed right away that's okay i
trust this guy i trust this man with my
life
he's already saved me like three times
look at my gun
oh shoot
wrong button
you know what go on friend
you deserve better
wait i changed my mind there we go i
forgot i have my settings if i want to
reload i have to hold
square that's my settings right now
you can't launch the game on your series
x as alex rodriguez
i wonder aaron have you been having any
trouble have you tried um
logging into i feel like
call of duty and xbox over the last year
has not been favorable and that's
so bad
that's like not there
we out we out okay let's go
okay let's buy our friends back that's a
good idea
crap
don't behind the bush the bush can't
kill you can't die that way
it was a slow death that was terrible
it's all up to the homie wow this dude's
already got a gold gun with a cool
reticle
ah
the homie didn't make it
that wasn't that bad i didn't get a lot
of kills but you have to see more of the
map at least
oh yeah
how we feeling chat how's this uh
looking you guys so far it's a little
buggy but
that'll all iron out it has to
let's try again
all right
you guys like my
coffee cup
focus please
it won't focus it's just it's snoopy
please why can't you oh hold on manually
i'm not gonna mess with this camera it's
snoopy it's great
it was really hot this morning
i love it i love a good dermis it almost
burned my tongue
all right chad says game keeps crashing
on me on the playstation 5. i'm going to
redownload it now and see if that helps
currently only own modern warfare oh if
you if you don't own vanguard you can't
play today
uh people who own vanguard get 24-hour
early access
so if you don't
have vanguard i'm afraid you can't play
today
monroe monroe i want to say her name
right
no
maniru maneru
i hope that helps i'm sorry if it
doesn't work out
fortunately for me the only thing that's
been consistent is getting into a game
everything else is like buggy and crashy
but at least we're getting into games
drunken cynic says can't even get in the
game keep saying unable to access
services services
it's a hot day for this
i i'm i'm gathering i thought it'd be
chill because not everyone has vanguard
but
i thought wrong
check your fire
hostile into the area watch the skies
oh no he's down
well i'm not gonna i shouldn't hide in
here let me look around while i can
look at the beautiful beach
although with with these uh with these
block things it's a little scary just
reminds us of
war but this is wars wow look at this
guy's gun
come on game
oh you mean modern warfare is actually
crashing
it's weird
i wish these games you know when you
start up these games and it lets you
pick between modern warfare
cold war vanguard and war zone i wish
they would just separate i don't care to
have them all together i think
uh it affects the game that way like
just now when you're trying to download
something for another game
your game gets affected like that's not
cool at least i think that's how it
works
all right let me pick a spot i am the
leader here let's go to the airstrip
what do you say fellas
man just jumped he didn't even i'm the
squad leader no one's paying attention
to me
oh my god
oh
boy
all right if everyone's okay
looks like they're trying to make their
way there that's cool
the airstrip yeah
let's do it friends
man i'm sorry you guys everyone in chat
seems to have some sort of technical
issue with this this morning
man already died no
oh he landed way down there
no don't take that plane it's already
being stolen
stick to the plan guys orange pink
you guys ever no never mind i was gonna
say the sideways parachuting thing
actually works but it's like the oldest
trick in the book now
going sideways gets you
pushes you like keeps you in the air
what am i trying to say
um
increases the range of how far you can
go on your
freaking
parachute wow i cannot talk today anyway
you know the movement
no one's around me so i'm just going to
go for it
[Music]
okay they're kind of around me but
they're in trouble
i don't think i want the smoke oh my god
i'm gonna crash
what the hell i changed seats
just like in battlefield
uh we can change seats and stay in the
air that's cool
i guess you could have done that with
the helicopter if you wanted to
what are these little oh
woohoo
look my teammate got a plane too
excellent
i think
yep
good luck friend i'll see you in the
skies
i hope i will be able to play the new
map i could not play verdance for weeks
due to errors oh man
i hope you can too you have to have
vanguard to play it today but tomorrow
it will be
free for everyone to play
free look oh you can free look whoa
wait this is free look
wow sorry if i'm making anyone sick
fire
roll
air brakes that's so funny
oh yeah there they are
no
no no i'm under attack
i just want to fly around
wow i'm trying to start a fight in the
air though
uh that guy was shooting a guns i think
no no i gotta pull up whoa
[Laughter]
that's cool i got some shots on that guy
let me turn around try again
oh no i don't even have money to buy
back my friends they're going to leave
[Laughter]
too low
i deserve that no i don't that was that
was great that was worth it that guy's
probably revived already though
well for those of you just joining in
you get to see the gulag now it's uh
it's the gulag
no first person view oh in the
helicopter i'll check that out next time
i didn't i didn't mess with that
oh man
it's time
watch this
no no no no damn we were both playing it
real sneaky
oh but it's over now i was the last guy
wasn't i
yeah
wow
disgusting
hit your brakes when you're turning to
turn faster oh thank you guys i think i
accidentally set
the stream delay to be
like extra long i forget when i did that
it's like
30 seconds or more so if i don't see
your comments and
reply to them immediately then uh that's
why i gotta
adjust the delay but thank you for all
the tips and tricks
the helic are the uh the plane is really
cool so far i really like it does some
damage too i downed an enemy
like you know a flash it was great
it might even be no i don't want to say
it they're not op that's
you're getting shot by a helicopter of
course she'll die fast
duh
on xbox aaron says it seems to be
consolidating all games why why is it
doing that if anything you should be
trying to separate them man
how are we doing in the chat are you
guys having any luck remember you if you
want to play the new caldera map you
have to own vanguard first
but for everyone else if even if you
don't own vanguard tomorrow you'll be
able to play this new map
but apparently we're having some um
technical issues across the board chat
has been keeping me up to date crashing
can't open the game
not working on playstation 5.
i don't know how i've been so fortunate
so far oh no
mr j the threat is on my team
tank the frank that's funny
wow that guy got the panda
operator skin that looked pretty funny
okay
so in vanguard royale which is the mode
i'm specifically playing you can't use
modern warfare cold war guns you can't
use any of that except you can only use
vanguard guns
which is what i like like
i think original warzone had like
130 guns and equipment like it was a big
number
i don't know how they made it work for
so long but
if you play this mode it's kind of like
a refresh like uh just vanguard guns
even though someone was saying in the
chat earlier even though uh vanguard
guns are pretty nuts on their own
the war zone okay let's do it
evan langer in the chat would will there
be an atlantic map to complement the
pacific
i'm afraid not uh you see evan i don't
think
never mind
i don't know anything about
like this whole game is already very
historically inaccurate so they might as
well make an atlantic map
chimpanzee
why is caldera in quotes
airfield let's do it again all right
cool i'm down
oh but there's oh they're four of us
okay good for a sec i thought they were
just three
i like to wait as long as i can like
right here i don't know why
i don't think it aids me at all
i just hate getting shot out of the air
um
i i really hate that i don't know why
like you shouldn't have you shouldn't be
able to pull your gun out in the air i'm
really petty over that
there's a few people
oops
that's got to be so much easier on pc
like accurately pinging things look at
that i missed
i missed
here i am playing on console like a
scrub no i'm kidding i've played on
console forever it's just how it is for
me
i tried um
call of duty one it's only on pc i
really had to dust off the old mouse and
keyboard skills man
i'm going for that plane right there
y'all drop too early
imo
crap
see you suckers
okay i can't fly that low
because those a guns are kind of
everywhere oh my god i'm going to crash
that was so bad oh my god
terrible i'm
sorry you had to see that
god
what am i doing i can skip this
same old that same old gulag but um
it's cool that it's like underground but
this kind of looks like you know that
shack style that quick construction
style of the old gulag too
never thought i'd miss the old actual
gulag from the prison i guess i don't
but
i'm such uh oh here we go wish me luck
but if you lose
i guess here
he's in here
did i get him all right
great
what's up joshua perez with the ellipses
in the chat just just
silence good to have you here brother
well
i guess i should try to catch up with my
team where are they there's one
tank the frank let's do it i'll hang out
with you
wait there's a bad guy coming down
all right lots of good stuff
what's this do nothing
nothing
oh look at this thing
oh let's roll out man let's do this you
want a gun or drive
okay
oh it's a mobile like a a gun this is
really cool
espa
not sure what you mean
spanish espanol
can you shoot with the plane yes i can i
died right away so i didn't get to show
you guys but um
um
why did we get out of here
exactly we're toast
i was unprepared
shoot shoot shoot
come on don't hear my footsteps
homie took care of them
let's see if we can uh do we have enough
to buy our friend back oh no our
friend's back
no one's dead great all right i'm the
only one that's died so far i think
oh
get out of here
all right looks like we're linking up
orange is coming back good to see you
right that's my secondary yeah i want a
different gun
yeah i'll take that
all right
where's green going green seems to be a
good leader i'll i'll stay on him
tank the frank that's green okay
ah see
um i do speak some spanish
um i would butcher it so you know i'm
not gonna do that right now
but yes
what the hell
okay whoa is that drivable no way
absolutely not
i wasn't anywhere near that door how did
i kick it open [ __ ]
dang it
no
i
almost downed him going around flanking
this dude i should have pinged him
terrible teammate what do you want me to
say
there's stuff going on behind us too
watch he's gonna he's gonna swoop around
right here
just telling you telling you i will camp
here no i won't
he's here somewhere
i hear him
hmm
as soon as i let my guard down he's
gonna pop out of nowhere swear watch
he's hiding or something
it's you again
[Laughter]
goodness gracious that's for my friend
sorry am i being too loud
okay there's another enemy near purple
where is purple on the map
oh he's not that far okay let's go let's
go let's go
oh man
that's a mess out here i'm gonna stay
inside look at our our target is getting
away
die
can i stun him in there
wait our target is still here
our target didn't take off
oh boy
wow jump in the window richie come on
for goodness sake oh i can't
oh god
i'm stressing out y'all
the game audio is too low
okay i will change that uh i appreciate
that sort of feedback you guys thank you
let me hide out here and turn it up just
a little
uh in our cue in our
little test this morning
we had to adjust it quite a bit
okay
i hope this helps thank you ghost for
letting me know
i'll take this hell yeah
and this hell yeah this guy was packing
okay
oh look at all my teammates so far away
i'm about to get gas what is this oh
yeah i'll take that too
i'll catch up i wanted to take a plane
there's still a few over here but
i think i'll just roll with my teammates
sounds like the safer thing to do
where's the nearest buy station i have
way too much money i can buy a loadout
and my friend back you see here
oh he already pinged it i'm such a bad
teammate
crap i have to run across
that's terrible
well i'm just gonna have to do it
don't kill me please
i'll buy us a loadout if i make it
i'll buy the other teammate too
come on come on
okay this guy's alive
then i'll buy let's do it i'll buy a
loadout marker
don't leave chimpanzee what are you
doing bro you don't want this oh there's
a free loadout over there i'm an 88
uh i'll take that stg class whatever
let's go that's not the stg class
i goofed
alright let's get the hell out of here
uh our teammate dipped he grabbed that
car and he left
wait i heard something over here
oh i think it's upstairs
whoa
come on purple it's just me and you i
guess
such a noob i didn't even reload this
gun
oh no they killed chimpanzee
is he the one in the plane
oh
enemy enemy
i am trash at this game
i should have cluster strike them i'll
save that for
later he knows i'm here though
i hate to do this to you man
i've been there so many times just
trying to get out of the gas and then
get
lit up sorry i had to do that
does he have any more teammates coming
okay let's roll purple
his uh clan tag is hate me
reload yes thank you marcos i'm sorry
so rusty at all this dude like just
general gameplay i love this game but
i haven't played you know in a bit
someone up there
want to take the plane
oh crap i'll keep this up hold on hold
on hold up
who's doing that
watch i'm gonna get sniped
forget it let's go
i wish we could take this plane this is
from the campaign i think no it's
not incoming
you want money
here uh take it all
skirt oh wow i can't slide into the
plane
come on man gas is coming in we should
move
you know what i might just take it slow
it's been a good game this is a
actually uh
not a bad game for me
can you just use vanguard guns or modern
warfare and cold war guns as well this
mode is called vanguard royale this mode
specifically and it only allows for
vanguard guns but
another playlist
will be here soon and you can use all
the guns just not today i don't think
what the okay that's friendly
whoa all right
go go go just go without me god i can't
even there i'm in i mean i'm in
you got this man just drive
he'll join if he wants
oh how far do you want to go man
okay to the ring that's good makes sense
[Music]
man i keep thinking those are just
regular in-game sound effects like just
background noise but those are people
flying planes that's so cool
oh no
why would you
[Music]
i don't know why you did that man
oh so buggy
[Music]
shoot let's get the hell out of here
boys
gas is closing
prices are back to normal
right on thank you
thank you for the ping
wish our fourth teammate was here he
left we could have bought him back
what's up
oh no
and i was about to use my cluster strike
i think this is the end friends
man
[Music]
oh
i thought we'd place higher but that was
not a bad game
how we doing chat
let's just try again
last i checked at 6am pacific standard
time i still couldn't get on warzone and
yes i own vanguard that's a problem then
that's that's not cool if you know what
they said something in the blog post
that you have to like
uh if you own vanguard and you wanted to
play you know 24 hours early like i am
you had to have got into a match
yesterday you had you had to play
multiplayer or something you had to
play vanguard yesterday or like the day
before to like claim your spot that
might be it
um i
which would stink i hope not but
they were it was kind of a specific rule
steven parsons yeah this is the new map
um there's a pretty long stream delay so
i'm trying to keep up as much as i can
oh yeah the key lease that's funny yep
that's tomorrow at
5 p.m
here on the west coast
five to eight i think
well let's just try again so far the
servers have been okay we had some funny
bugs the uh the spiky glitchy guns were
back
some texture issues but it's getting
better
like
we love to see that
sammy thank you for being here
thank you guys all for being here
oh
man
yes i did play warzone and vanguard
yesterday so if that's the case there
may be another problem
i agree
that's
crap you did everything right you have
vanguard um
i wish i could i wish i could help
further but it sounds like you did
everything right
someone in the chat earlier straight up
deleted the game and reinstalled it i
think they i haven't
i don't know if they've chimed in to say
that it worked but
it might work i definitely don't want to
recommend that though because that this
is a big ass game
oh look a pirate ship
or just you know a
ship not a pirate ship
skull and crossbones just a
old ass ship that's cool though
wow
is it the resulca rusolka from uh black
ops nah it can't be why would it be
although do you guys hear uh if you're
playing vanguard multiplayer they
dropped a new map today because it's
season one starting today
and the new map i forget what it's
called but it's a remake of modern
warfare 3 dome cannot believe it
so they're taking infinity ward assets
they're taking um
treyarch assets and remaking them it's
kind of weird it's cool
i only have to delete save files oh okay
that's for
that might be for good advice for hugh
in the chat
raphael uh pacific or verdansk verdansk
is gone man it's just the pacific map
now
versus firestorm you know i never played
firestorm i think aaron can
jump in in the chat
and uh
talk about firestorm
what are my thoughts so far on the new
war zone versus the old war zone better
same worse you must pick one hmm
i'm having fun it's a hard time to ask
me that question because everything's so
new
so right now my first thoughts are like
better um there's there's
you know
i'm having a really good time so far it
could there's probably going to be
problems people come across and
overpowered this and that but on day one
right now i'm having fun
and it's a nice break away from verdansk
so i would say better at the moment you
know
it's not an official review or anything
what the hell am i doing
this guy wanted a landlord volcano no
i'm
i'm gonna go away i don't know
are they really landing here
sorry
if you guys didn't know i hate to hot
drop
i'm a i'm a i'm a chill
oh man oh no
goodness gracious no
yeah i've never liked hot drops i got
into battle royale like pretty much with
apex legends
and people who are gung-ho like that
they're a different breed man i cannot
jeez me
it's free for people who don't own
vanguard is it free for people who don't
own vanguard yes tomorrow
this new map will be available for free
for everyone you don't even have to own
vanguard but tomorrow you win this fight
and you return to the front line but if
you lose you're done
i'm toast i hate
all right i like when i win the gulog
doesn't happen much
all right let's catch up with the homies
where they at
oh they're right below wait there's one
there they okay they're all in the
building right below me excellent
i like that you get to keep your gulag
gun that might have been a thing for a
while i actually haven't played warzone
in a minute
played some vanguard but not warzone
did you guys see our
um firearm expert reacts video to
vanguard he reviewed this little handgun
that i'm holding
um
wrong emote but whatever anyway jonathan
reviewed and he tore it up it's great
even this little handgun was
pretty inaccurate it was so funny to see
him just talk [ __ ] about it
in his very elegant way i love jonathan
ferguson
okay well we are here all four of us we
boys we out here
let's try to get a win
although this place doesn't have many oh
oh god another one
uh this place doesn't have any weapons
so far i gotta i gotta find more
i have this i actually don't like this
gun very much
weapons weapon hey here we go here's
some stuff yeah i'll take this
no i don't know if i should have done
that
i thought it was an smg
come on man give me one of these what
the hell
cool i remember this thing
a hot spring that could have killed us
cool
how we doing chat i'll check the game
out when i get home after work thanks
aaron yeah aaron thank you
appreciate you
aaron sampson everyone
let's see here
we're all going down okay
this is so fun this little this gun is
so funny
this is an actual
gun come on i'll take
yeah
whoa no
is that up the hill or a plane i'll take
that
i actually need this now y'all want
y'all want in
who shot at us i think it was a plane
no i think i would have heard it for a
plane
why don't we just get the f out of here
huh
ah more people yeah i'm so sorry about
these
connectivity issues this morning we're
all we all seem to be having them some
harder than others though
this little okay it's the carbine oh
yeah give me that
um
which one
ammo i think i already picked that up
didn't i
i did this already yeah totally did
all right friends
let's see i gotta find we need money for
a loadout that whoa mr green over here
has got so much money let's where's the
shop
you need a buy station what do you guys
think
sniper rifle
i mean i might take that sniper rifle
actually hold on that's the m1
i might try that out i haven't tried the
m1 yet look at this scope
it looks
ridiculous when you're holding it like
this but this looks pretty normal
the new map how was the new map thank
you for asking um i like it so far it's
really cool tomorrow if um you should be
able to play like for free i hope you
get to check it out because
it's really nice
it's beautiful which is strange to say
just all green you know like
um
but i'm having fun the layout is also
good everything is also new so we're all
excited here hype for real hype train
enemy
active uh i'm still [ __ ] at this game
though so there's that
so what's wrong here this guy's uh
guys looking for the smoke yeah i'll
take this scg
for sure
that uh
grenade launcher was cool and pretty
kitschy but
oh i pinged the stupid market the stupid
buy station and i didn't even
go to it i guess i'll unping it
oh no i didn't ping that one
so scatterbrained you guys what a time
to be alive
thanks for being here appreciate you
guys in the chat
for me here on the west coast it is
almost 11 a.m
where you guys from what time is it
there i love
i love hearing that i forget how much
game spot
um
viewers are just so scattered all over
the world it's really cool it's so
impressive every stream i like to ask
like hey where you from what time is it
there
stg let's do it and then i think i might
take that m1 back
um i like the bazooka though now i'll
take the m1
oh shoot someone might be on our tail
lads
i'm gonna hide out here
come on you guys
hurry up
the music is also good i've been i've
been enjoying like the menu music and
stuff
and just the score
that's all new
oh i heard a sniper bullet
whiz past my head
oh great
shoot get the hell out of here
a little camp there
who's dropping money
it looks like it has less dark spots
like in verdance
yeah the sun is like
higher in the air and i think that just
makes the map like brighter i'm probably
just talking [ __ ] but
like i know what i'm talking about but
you're right bottom line there i think
there are less dark spots everything's a
lot sunnier it's great
what is this cluster strike
y'all don't want this
go ahead
all right i'll take it
oh there's another one uav
money
you don't want that
um i don't have much i'll take it sure
i'll give back whatever i could use that
there you go self revive kit yeah and
then i'll see here you can have the rest
of my money
we're in this together
go ahead i already bought mine
come on orange you need anything
no
i already bought not me all right
can i give you a thumbs up nope i just
went into single mode there we go thumbs
up someone take this yeah go ahead you
take this i already bought what i needed
we can't be this generous on the
battlefield
but they're
airplanes trying to kill us and we're
trying to give each other money you know
what i'll take it fine just to have it
what else can i buy
look okay good i'll take this i don't
have one of those thank you teammate
oh okay do i solve the m1 yes i do oh
shoot
you know what i have one too
get out of here
[Music]
no they got orange let's go get him
you'll
live
all right
that airstrike didn't do [ __ ] but they
should be on their way here now
oh no
she says what i was thinking
i am trash
where is this fool hiding behind the
bush
you know what
wow that was such a [ __ ] throw they
forgot how nerfed that c4 is
die
[Laughter]
hey man can you revive me nope he's in
trouble
help me out bro can you you got a sec
dude this man doesn't give an
f about me
you know what
i'm going to be the bigger man here and
try to help you out
two of my teammates are down
no i'm getting hit oh no he's punching
me
oh wow that dude was a melee monster i
gotta give it to him whenever i just
i'll take that l
that was embarrassingly bad but good for
him he must feel he must have felt so
cool
you're just going to spend it all in a
res kit
have you unlocked the new phosphorus
grenade and
and if yes is it op like i'm hearing i
have not unlocked the phosphorus grenade
forgot about that
um
i have all these tokens i gotta use too
i should really like
get back into vanguard i did have fun
during like the play tests and the beta
and stuff
um but i've been playing so much
grand theft auto that i kind of fallen
off call of duty sounds so funny but
i love that definitive edition man i
just love that game
um
so it's funny because we made a video
about you know the the things it needs
to fix all the bugs and glitches but
i'm still having so much fun with gta
that um
it doesn't matter and they're you know
they're trying to fix it it was rushed
for sure but
i'm still having
loads of fun
oh man relax i hate when people just
spray your dead body like chill you won
dude don't be a sore winner
that's just me
that c4 throw though
that was [ __ ] huh it was so bad
oh god
they nerfed it to filth i forgot how bad
that c4 throw is
this guy's just having the time of his
life
well
the life that ended
all right friends i think i might have
time for like
one or two more
debates in the chat says imagine
watching this guy not doctor disrespect
i mean you know where to find him go
ahead i mean you're
you're here i appreciate you being here
but yeah
i'm a humble
warzone player just trying to have some
fun
uh either way thanks for being here he's
probably gone watching doctor disrespect
but here we go let's try again
only vanguard guns oh cool okay great
you guys earlier answered my question
about where you're from what time it is
11 a.m you're from iowa cool
in france
nice oh i love that that um
internationally outside of america you
know in a lot of places they they tell
the time we call it military time or
it's a 24-hour clock that makes so much
more sense
like it makes so much more sense anyway
thank you for love from france love it
water cannot kill you now that's very
true isn't that cool you can't die like
water is lightly swimmable i think
only vanguard guns ian asked yeah that's
true only vanguard guns in this mode is
called vanguard royale tomorrow though
more playlists will be unlocked
and i think you can use
all the guns
planes are hard to pilot yeah the very
first time i got into one
i couldn't it couldn't it wouldn't take
off i was like what's with these
controls but i finally got it down it's
it's
it doesn't take much time for it to like
get off the airstrip so
once you get past that it's not that bad
to control
clean scope view this is all from
earlier in the chat thank you guys for
chatting it up with me appreciate the
questions and the uh just being here
it's nice
that's the whole point of streaming
right we're just hanging out
okay cool we got into
another um
lobby here with david ricky bobby and
wolf pack united states marine corps
i had an old friend who um
he
[Music]
he joined the army and i was like you
know what made you do that i don't think
you have any family in the army or
anything like that you know
he was like nah i just watched a lot of
24 and i was bored so i joined the army
i was like damn all right
thank you for your service and now he's
uh he uh
he's not an army anymore but
he was
oh no don't kill me
check your fire bro
man i thought i had her
oh that's a cool banner
yep ricky bobby is here
hey matt
yeah okay let's see here we go here let
me just take a look at this map for
those of you joining in like
haven't had a thorough look at the
layout yet i don't know how helpful this
is but
goodness that's a lot of trees look at
that
there are they make a lot of shade there
are some dark dark spots but overall i'm
really enjoying the look of
caldera
whoa
did you guys play vanguard like the
campaign i really enjoyed it
um cheesy inaccurate action-packed
yes all true but i still had fun
where do you guys want to go
why don't we hit up the airstrip again
all right everyone's disagreeing with me
gotta roll with the team
i actually haven't been over here yet so
this is good this is good
please don't shoot
a lot of people don't shoot me
i hate i already said it but i hate
being shot out of the air like can we
just land and then you can shoot me
please
like civilized
all right there's purple down there
where's my other teammate oh here he is
orange
why is there only three i guess it
didn't load quads all the way
i want to go for the contract instead
okay
what the flim flam
great
wow look at this area arsenal
it's like where they load ships this is
cool
look like big bathtubs
uk 7 pm oh thank you for being here
love it
i hope you're able to play if you want
to um
for people who are wondering or just
don't know
you can play this 24 hours early like i
am if you have vanguard
you own vanguard and if you you know
played it recently
whoa this is really high up
um yeah let's see
just to be safe
i heard glass breaking dudes not good
freaking out already guys
okay it's just my friend
whoa
stupid gun come on come on come on come
on come on peek
he's here okay
see me did you
sorry
i can't believe i let them kill my
friend
that person had like a
gun with all the attachments on it what
was that
oh i love this gun yeah this is my
favorite gun in the whole game you guys
um it's actually pretty op it has a
built-in
shield for uh enemy suppression
as part of the new update you can only
get it if
you played vanguard early
stupid stupid stupid
gun i'm scared that gun is still [ __ ]
watch oh my god i can't play like this
i'm already at a severe disadvantage
because i stink at this game but i can't
have that
come on
where's my purple teammate your teammate
has failed they're sent back to base
oh my gosh
oh i heard i heard him breaking in
no not again
are you really shooting me with that
little handgun
no i can't i can't even this is uh not
functional
someone's up here too damn it i'm gonna
hide i'm gonna hide like a little coward
everyone be very quiet
enemy cluster strike watch your heads
watch your heads
oh i can't believe i'm stuck
with this gun
great now they're gonna find me i'm
toast
just close the door on that
i'm freaking out dude they're gonna find
me trying not to make any noise
oh it's me i'm freaking out over my own
footsteps
i wonder if they see my purple teammate
over there
you know what i should go for that buy
back
i'm gonna buy my friend back we could
use all the help why did what the hell
is this
i gotta have to go back up
all right go go go go go go i'm gonna
buy my teammate back
hang in there
this is pretty open that's okay
they were way too closed off it'd be
unrealistic like come on
bye my friend back where's my friend
come on
and this area has not been searched
here drop here and grab all this good
stuff man
actually [ __ ] i need some good stuff hey
my gun works again
drop that gun no look alien look it
works again
salty dog says it is 8 13 am on thursday
bless up from new zealand i love it
ah thanks man
thanks friend thanks for being here
love from new zealand
everything i learned about new zealand i
i i like i want to go there someday
although i heard the you know obviously
the plane ride is oh drop some money
thanks man
look david on the bottom left is
chatting to us but i can't hear
i think i turned all chat off
where is david he's purple right where
is he
is he alive
no okay for a second it showed up
gulag
nevermind
have enough money i'm gonna buy him back
he's dead right or he's in the gulag
that's the problem what am i doing
i'm freaking out i'm spinning around
like a madman
but if he loses the gulag i'll buy him
back i'll be ready
i wish i could just pull him out of the
gulag
come on come on come on come on come on
david come back
come on
dave head why can't i'm back
what the
oh no this stinks i i gotta move
oh there we go god that took forever
buy your buddy back yeah
did ps5 get feel the vision slider no it
didn't we were talking about that
earlier no luck
let me double check i just saw that
charlie intel on twitter confirmed it
earlier this morning but i haven't
looked for myself
yeah it's the same old modern warfare
style
menu
and i don't think they added
um oh no it's the um
yeah this looks like modern warfare i
don't see anything for
you know feel the vision no luck oh the
loadout let me go let's go let's go
let's go let's go
no one's over here this is great
this looks like a room straight out of
her dance guy i won't lie to you
hold on
come on jump jump man jump
someone's over there i gotta make this
quick they're fighting each other too
okay
don't want the bazooka i'll pick up the
other
enemy
get the hell out of here
wow the other one i had i picked up the
wrong scg i have two of them and i got
them wrong
the one i wanted had like all the
attachments on it oh well
how's the new map i'm waiting for mine
to update so far it's really cool i mean
in my personal opinion
um i'm having fun it's just nice you
know it's brand new shiny fun
i haven't really found any devastating
flaws except for some technical like
visual glitches you know
uh but i'm liking it so far
my teammate is shooting someone out
there in the wild
david needs shields where are you going
david david in the purple needs to relax
i've been able to get fov on ps5 for a
while now it's set to 104. yeah that's
usually what i set it at like 100-ish
for cold war
um
warzone stinks
i'm running around getting zero kills
let's let's make some moves
do it for the do for the chat
yeah why not
no fov in war zone sadly no aaron
i think it was confirmed this morning
when people got their hands on it
charlie intel tweeted that uh
it's not
there all right what is
what's his name wolf pack come on we
gotta move
where's the ring we're actually we're
not doing too bad maybe i shouldn't push
it
some of my best games in warzone and
like apex we're just chilling straight
chilling and then like getting a few
kills at the end
okay maybe i'm gonna check out this
building again this is where we started
isn't it
i hear a box
oh must be on the roof or the second
floor
hunt them down hunt them down
where
you want money david
i'll drop some i don't have much
what is this what's my secondary another
stg i'll take this nz
new zealand
all right let me um
move it
i physically move my head as if someone
like as a as if i could look out the
window i still do that like a kid
you ever play driving games like that
like where you're turning the controller
oh no someone's bombing our teammate get
out of there
i will go back here
holy crap
[Music]
he got bombed
and
like an
air strike
or whatever they're called um
and he lived bottom line this dude is a
sav
like gunning run what is it called
level with me is it worth buying
vanguard or just rolling with the free
version um
that's a loaded question with a lot of
um i like vanguard so i can say like
yeah you should buy it um
but you know i don't want to
uh
i think i think you should try warzone
out tomorrow for free using the vanguard
guns the new pacific map and then if you
really
if you really like
how it plays
um you can pick up vanguard for like
more more of that but for me i'm like
you know i happen to have both and i'm
i'm chilling i'm having fun
but worth buying i don't know
i think a good way to test it out like i
said
is just um
playing warzone for free that's like the
happy middle ground and it's free free
free free free
why was no one on this
when did i get one killed
was it the gulag do you guys remember
you mean strafe yeah yeah the strafing
run thank you
king porkchop love it that's the one
strafing run
i think it goes by you know god every
call of duty's got some version of that
and they call it something else every
time
all right
oh definitely no c4 you guys remember
what happened last time i'm not a good
c4 user
targets let's go oh i wish i had
something more long range
[Music]
holy
why would i do that
take them down
the shimmer of the curtains made me
think someone was there but it's just
this
shimmer
no man andre andre
apollo no fov i'm sorry to say
[Music]
how do you
come on how did he get him where where
is this person
is he still there no i saw him run
towards the safe zone
oh crap
wish me luck
[Laughter]
i downed one
what am i doing i should move too
i'm about to get gas
well at least i was able to pick off
some fools see here
run run
run oh man what's his name left us
dude's trying to take a plane out of the
gas it might work but
we're watching you
yes i got that guy yeah
rebirth isn't fun anymore
man uh that's what chad is saying i i
have a mixed relationship with with
rebirth
it was nice to have something other than
verdansk
um
i don't know i fell off rebirth pretty
quick
everything's a hot drop and i don't play
that way you guys know me or you guys
might know me wait
wait
you want any of this if he selfie
what am i doing
i guess that's why he was running away
enemies in the truck all right
crap crap crap
well it's me and wolf pack
then there were two we're still playing
quads ivan asks do you like the new map
yes i do so far i'm enjoying it
it's not blowing my mind it still feels
very much like war zone but the
environment change is very welcome so
i'm happy
it's clear crap
this dude's gonna run right into the
thick of it man
i'm scared to move
okay that truck is moving
this man is braver than i am or this
person who is it wolf pack
usmc
oh
i need a better secondary we're going to
get close real soon so i need something
faster
smg or something another one of these
come on now dog
no he's down
no
why is it up to me
my man was too bold
someone did a buyback
[ __ ]
what the oh no
no
deadly silence let's go faster faster go
go go go i'm toast
i'm screwed
crap
up here's where it's hot but
oh i don't want to cough i don't want to
make noise
got one
sorry oh no
i'm paying for this
damn it
look at this guy's thompson looks like a
toy
got me i was bested friends
well that that worked out really nicely
it's like 11 30 our time so i'm just
gonna i'm gonna wrap up the stream here
friends let me switch over to this
yes and tell you how thankful i am that
you were here today let me shut this up
for a sec so i can talk there we go
appreciate you guys being here today um
caldera is available for anyone who has
played who owns vanguard you get 24-hour
early access if you've played vanguard
and you own it
for everyone else this map is available
available tomorrow uh free so
get in i hope you have fun and i'll see
you guys next time appreciate you being
here i'll see you
where is it fair
what i found it oh got it bye
you